I'm joined today by Sara bunin the nor
an associate professor of contemporary
Jewish Studies at Hebrew Union College
in Los Angeles and author of becoming
from how newcomers learn the language
and culture of Orthodox Judaism uh Sarah
so great to talk to you you know we've
we've interviewed a number of different
people generally in the world of
linguistics and we've talked about the
different dialects and accents that
exist in the United States but one that
I've increasingly been reading about is
what sort of colloquially known as the
Jewish accent and I think that there's
many people who sort of intuitively know
what it is that we're talking about but
how is this defined academically what
are we talking about when we say the
Jewish accent well I would say there are
two different types of Jewish accents
the one that you're probably referring
to is the New York Jewish accent that's
immigrant influenced by immigrant
Yiddish and probably spoken by the
children and grandchildren of immigrants
and then there's the accent of Orthodox
Jews throughout the english-speaking
world where their English is influenced
by Yiddish grammatical structures and
Yiddish sounds in a slightly different
way than the immigrant generation and
their children and grandchildren so I
have friends who who sometimes will
disagree about when you're talking about
the the often sort of uh immigrant at
New York associated so-called Jewish
accent there's disagreement as to
whether we're talking about something
distinct and unique in in terms of a
Jewish accent or whether we're really
talking about a particular sort of
neighborhood be it Lower East Side or
Brooklyn version of just a New York
accent is one or the other view right or
wrong yeah I think you're absolutely
right that the the New York accent is
sometimes seen as a Jewish accent and
that has to do with the large New York
Jewish population
it but um I I would say that there are
certainly Jews who are not from New York
who sound like they are from New Yorker
who have elements of a New York accent
and when we talk about that is this a
phenomena that was first identified sort
of in the early 20th century with the
wave of immigration to certain parts of
New York City or what other sort of
historical connections have been
associated with this yes the historical
wave of immigration to New York from
Eastern Europe between 1880 and 1924
played a big role in the establishment
of a distinctive Jewish sound you might
call it an ethnic way of speaking and
you can see this in other ethnic
communities throughout the United States
in in different regions such as the
German population in Wisconsin or the
african-american population in various
cities or Latino population in various
cities that if if an ethnic group has a
large concentration in a given area then
they will likely have distinctive
features in their language now you've
done some research which has revealed
that even among Jews who are not from
New York themselves and even whose
parents did not live or from New York
that there's a much higher likelihood
that they will exhibit some of the
characteristics that are often common to
this sort of Jewish accent that we're
talking about and this might include the
pronunciation of Florida versus Florida
and some other even phrases online
versus in line etc how do we explain
this how do we understand that right and
I personally do that myself my parents
are lived part of their childhood in New
York and the New York area and I didn't
grow up in New York but I say Florida
and horrible and I think it has to do
with the New York centered social
networks
that many
have that if if many Jews interact with
other people who have spent time in New
York or who grew up in New York then
these kinds of New York features will
spread and that's true in the non
Orthodox circles that I'm a part of but
it's also even more so in the Orthodox
world where there's a particular feature
I call it the non raising of pre nasal
ah so that is saying where it's like
candle and camp instead of candle and
camp right and and that feature is
common it I I think it started in New
York as a response to the New York valve
and then among Orthodox Jews and then
spread all throughout the country so
that people in Orthodox communities
around the u.s. have many of them have
that feature I've sort of anecdotally
observed during my time living in New
York City up until about a year ago and
also now living in Boston both cities
that have particular accents that are
that are often portrayed in media
etcetera that increasingly there seems
to be a sort of class element to
particularly with younger people who are
hearing more English in media and and
sort of non localized English accents uh
that it seems as though many of these
accents are becoming less common
particularly outside of lower middle
class individuals are my anecdotal
observations accurate in your mind or or
or maybe not yes there is certainly
evidence that the New York accent is
decreasing to some extent and you're
absolutely right that social class plays
an important role in how local people
tend to sound and when you when you sort
of try to think going forward I think
that there's you know we've we spoke for
example to the linguist William Leigh
Bob about uh his analysis of the
different accents that exist in the u.s.
what can we say more generally about I
mean are there it it it seems to me we
can't necessarily say that all of these
accents are going to be decreasing over
time
I'm maybe depending on how isolated
certain communities are I mean we know
that the Appalachian way of speaking
maybe is going to persist more strongly
because it's it's maybe a more isolated
community than maybe your average New
Yorker I don't know I mean is there some
trend that we can observe right well the
New York accent has been shown to be
decreasing to some extent but other
regional accents around the country are
very strong for example in the Midwest
saying salad instead of salad is is
actually increasing and is widening in
the areas that it's used in so and the
California vowels are also becoming more
distinct in certain ways so so right I
don't think it's a nationwide trend of
the decrease in regional accents but
certainly the New York accent in
particular has diminished to some extent
do you have any opinion as to whether
media portrayals of accents uh tend to
sort of reinforce them in some way or
does it make others may be more aware of
speaking differences such that they
might try to avoid a localizing accent
maybe it's more of a psychology question
than anything else but you have some
sense of that yeah I think we don't have
enough evidence to answer the question
of the role of the media in influencing
the spread or decrease in regional
accents but we do have some idea of how
certain accents can become seen as a
particular accent because of the media
or for example in Pittsburgh saying
going downtown for downtown is has
become a has gained cachet and that
probably is influenced by the media and
by t-shirts that say those kinds of
phrases and that highlight the
distinctive Pittsburgh way of speaking
well it is absolutely fascinating I'll
remind you the book is becoming from how
newcomers learn the language and culture
of Orthodox Judaism we've been speaking
with the
books author Sarab union bin or who's an
associate professor of contemporary
Jewish Studies at Hebrew Union College
in Los Angeles Sarah thanks so much for
talking to us thanks so much for having
me